the younger people they are not
concerned about gun laws the legality
the illegality of guns concealed and
carry they just
they just know that
to move around they need a gun yeah or
to survive they need a gun that's their
feeling
[Music]
can you believe it i'm still here that's
right living inside this tent for 100
days from november 20th to february 28th
bringing to you the awareness that you
need to have about the violence on the
south side of chicago
and also to raise money to build a
community center on this block that is
much needed called o block it's called o
block because it's named after a young
man named od perry who was shot and
killed the gangs picked up the o and his
name and start calling it o block we
decided we're gonna keep the o but we're
gonna call it opportunity block i want
to thank fox for the opportunity they've
given me to bring to you every day my
thoughts my opinions my viewpoints here
on rooftop revelations
and
i want to thank my guests for being here
today i have a topic that we want to
talk about
and that's the chicago police and the
violence in chicago so i want to welcome
uh officer tracy quarles who
a sergeant when he retired served 25
years faithfully for the chicago police
department
thank you for being here today thank you
thank you i hope you don't freeze out
here in this cold
it would be the first time i was on the
roof i know that's right so listen i
want to ask you some questions i know a
lot of people are interested in the
chicago police department with all this
violence that's going on in chicago
people around the country want to know
uh
how is it
serving as a police officer in chicago
oh it's tough and fun
bittersweet all together it's hard to
explain unless you walk in those shoes
but it's a great opportunity for me
is it a highly stressful job
yes i worked in uh high crime ridden
areas
my entire 25 years on the streets
um
and but i i also came from the streets
and i when i say i came from the streets
i grew up on the west side of chicago
and at the age of 10 my mother we found
ourselves in cabrini green on the 16th
floor
1119 north cleveland yeah and
that's fun
[Music]
i understand for those who don't know
about cabrini greens cabrini green was
one of the largest
projects in the city of chicago with a
lot of different personalities and a lot
of different people who lived there as
well yeah i know you lived in pretty
greens and you went on to college and
then became a police officer
and i want to talk about these areas
where you started serving you know you
served in high crime area
we have a relationship because you serve
in this area uh a lot of the stuff that
i learned about uh gangs was asking you
questions about all the different games
in our neighborhood
and one of the things i want to ask you
about is just
the different way of policing
you know there's some police who take
the hands off approach and there's
others
like you who had a hands-on approach can
you tell
us why did you have such a hand on
approach
with criminals in this area
because they were my brothers and
sisters at the end of the day
a criminal would help you i found out in
a tough
situation um and they would hurt you too
but
these are people who look like me walk
like me talk like me i grew up
with a lot of them as you know
when most of the projects were torn down
many of them was displaced throughout
the city of chicago especially the south
side and south suburbs
i was t-mac and cabrini green so i was a
no stranger to the streets
they know that as a matter of fact when
i first got assigned over here they told
me you was in the game i called some of
the old heads that i knew some of the
leaders
hey is his name on the road
so remember that i i they're not came in
he came and talked to me and i said well
and we
that that and um
but you saw how i was i was the type i
would come and talk to you
i would see how i could help you
and i would
would just get close to people enough to
be comfortable
to understand what's driving
them to want to do a certain thing and
if i could redirect them
and you know i've redirected a lot of
folks right to your door absolutely you
brought a lot of kids to the school
you redirected a lot of guys who even
now work for us and helped a lot of guys
out i want to ask you um this question
about the violence
what do you think is driving it here in
the city why is it so bad
i think
younger people are experimenting
at an alarming rate
with uh
substance abuse
um
specifically different kinds of peels
and these gummy bears um
and of course this
new type of weed they got out
um so i think it's substance abuse
being used at a young age and they're
making awful decisions especially when
they get their hands on guns and so
forth yeah and guns are plenties in
chicago i heard one statistic that said
uh
half
of the boys between the ages of 15 to 25
are carrying weapons does that sound
about right
that sounds right um and it's it's
probably
higher or higher yeah
and these and we're talking about
them carrying illegal guns we're not
talking about second amendment we're not
talking about people who have a legal
right to have a gun we have no problem
with that we're talking about these
individuals who have illegal guns
they're carrying them they're using them
for criminal activity on one another and
making it bad for police as well yeah
well the younger people they are not
concerned about gun laws the legality
the illegality of guns concealed and
carry they just
they just know that
to move around they need a gun
or to survive they need a gun that's
that's their feeling and they're in a
lot of instances because the gangs are
in so many factions now
uh their movement
is limited right many of these young men
can't even come off at 64th and eberhard
over two king drivers which is two
blocks about two blocks yeah can't go
two blocks i think people need to
realize that too people who are
listening to us they don't realize that
there are kids in our neighborhood who
cannot go two or three or four blocks
exactly they they have to in many cases
if you go to the gas station you'll see
the guests they should be selling them
t-shirts and underwear yeah yeah gym
shoes and so because they can't go to
the store they can't get out there they
take us to prison yeah
and that's it's horrible nobody should
have to live in these conditions and
under these conditions that we're in you
know i i lived about eight blocks from
uh the church
and my son i would never allow him to
walk to the church never ever because
it's just too dangerous and
i i know there are other families who
feel that way but that robbed them when
we lived in cabrini i walked downtown i
took uh oak street
and walked up to rush street we walked
uh division we walked walk walk yeah and
that was because
gangs back then there was
some structure
and i don't advocate gangs or gang
membership or gang leadership but i do
believe that if some of the gang leaders
was let out
back to the streets
uh prefaced with they would be tasked
with
uh getting their organizations back
together for instance let's use the
black gangster disciples
which was
uh
a gang
which broke up to the bds and gds now
after larry hoover got locked up
uh king shorty king david were two on
the streets
a rift came
one took the bds one took the gds
and just that one organization just
think about this if they got back
together and stopped killing one another
yeah
that would
yeah especially if we could get them to
do something purposeful purposeful and
their leaders would be
if if i could get the president
or the vice president or someone to
listen to me hey let's give these guys
some type of conditional partner where
they would come back to the communities
where their gangs was started
and let's
be purposeful in helping them redirect
their lives
many say they don't listen to they won't
listen to them they would but it would
have to be twofold
not only
would you have to let the leaders out to
deal with their members out here you'd
have to relax the rico law many of the
leaders i know here in the city right
now
that
they're scared to do anything
street wise because they don't want to
get
tagged with being a gang leader under
the rico act right and that's a lifetime
in in prison so many of them are still
out here and their orders will
can exist
they can bring structure back
but they risk it
if they
get labeled as the leader of the game
absolutely absolutely you know let me
ask this last question there's a lot of
debate a lot of discussion around the uh
should we bring in the feds or should we
not bring the fed should we bring in the
national guard or not bring the national
guard what do you think about bringing
in the national guard
well as i said when when you ask that
earlier
we pay taxes we're this chicago right
now this is a public health crisis uh
the shootings and the the
murders that are following up on i mean
you can't even drive down the expressway
going to work
we just had lost a young lady
was shot in her head and i just found
out today she passed away from her
injuries
this is someone innocent driving down on
the expressway right so we're all all
involved now we all are subject to this
so we have to do something we you did
the gun buybacks yeah you've called me
anonymous
yeah
like there's a gun over here this guy
want to turn a gun in
i mean we've did that we did that so
we've got to do something different
we've got to do something different and
i would love to see the national guards
at the feds are already here they're
doing a wonderful job
[Music]
but we we need the protection of our
armed forces in chicago it's it's
something i've never seen
and i don't see it getting any better so
as a support role being visible
letting people know the good and bad
people know that we are here we're here
to make you feel safe
i welcome you yeah
well i want to thank you for coming on
today thank you for coming to the
rooftop and uh
i haven't seen you in a while especially
doing this pandemics it was a blessing
being able to see that you're doing good
and your family's doing well
as i always say to all of you who tune
in every day thank you so very much uh
for
listening to the rooftop revelations and
thank you for your support thanks fox
network and also thanks to eli steele
who is consistent in making sure that we
give you good information
as i always say until tomorrow
peace
peace
you